[Music]
hello world how's it goin Persia here
join my chastity today no see no streams
live but yeah guys we are here it is the
fifth which means Mario & Sonic at the
Olympic Games is out it's available is
here okay 2020 yes
let's go I'm very excited all right
I love Sonic I love Mario I love all
these things I'm pretty stoked about
many games for the win many games are so
many games don't get enough love there's
so much fun let's do this all right
yes so I was just telling chastity how I
played like a few minutes of the story
mode and it's a lot of dialogue and very
little gameplay so I'm leaning more edge
to it leaning more towards the quick
matches sounds good yeah we might be
sharing a controller I think so
so yeah we're just jumping right it they
got a lot of games on this and they
added some new ones like karate and I
think there's I think skateboarding is
near - yeah there's quite a few new
things here and then there's also the
retro games - you love it oh oh my god I
want to do that I want to do that have
at it
take your pick well I'll let you step up
for me yeah I haven't played it all it's
gonna be terrible oh yeah this is also
interest about so obviously traditional
way buttons only alright or I guess
there's a certain way you can do it with
like the motion control alright alright
safety's sake yes buttons only when you
start the game it's like make sure you
have ample you know uh - oh let's try
yeah let us play together please but
yeah guys this is Mario and Sonic at the
Olympic Games Tokyo 2020 this just
dropped today on the Nintendo switch
pretty stoked I haven't
played a single minute of it so good
luck I might need to sink this okay yeah
I need to press bend on the side yeah
now you're in now we're cooking cool all
right let's go hey nice Oh let's go oh
my god knuckles Mike who do I want to be
i 100% want to be knuckles knuckles is
great do you know how much I love you
knuckles I will be a lot I'll be tails
yeah hello everyone hey everyone in the
glove come thanks for joining us oh this
is so old-school I love it sure look at
the controls
you can't work okay cool Super Start
whole day then release speed up a review
they got it
nailed it cool Kendu I'm in Layton match
that a button let's go
oh no egg man's here and Louie and Luigi
I hope Oh nope I failed
damn scales get it tails Wow not even a
contest oh my goodness tails oh dang
hey Nathaniel thanks for joining us yeah
I messed up my superstar do you have old
I was just holding the whole time until
it's that guy so I don't know if there's
really I think it's that thing that
hatch right Mario Cart happened to oh
yeah yeah
all right very nice you got the gold I'm
proud of you oh it's okay I got silver I
like yeah we can run it back now that we
know the it's probably it happened to me
again so I'm just gonna hold it or maybe
there's a certain time here we go ready
I love the look of this nice oh oh
you're a beast I love it there's like
matching my rights look at the I love it
goodness I love it I love that they kept
kind of like the respective sprites from
both games like the mario sprites are
super pixelated and then the sonic one
has a little more detail oh good it's so
good yeah like they we've got the 8-bit
with the Mario sprites and the way we've
got like the 16-bit with the Tails and
Knuckles alright let's do another event
yeah let's do it
choose from alright let's do let's stick
with some old school for a bit let's see
how it looks good question Andrew said I
wanted to get this for my four year old
I think you would like the motion
controls can you try those out on a
couple events and let us know yeah yeah
we'll try out a few good shot we'll give
it a shot
alright in a judo match use different
judo techniques to score oh man they are
they're getting real with the
terminology and huh alright sure
alright let's try it on a video set I
love the bread face during extra life
stream for the kids yeah a good time we
played Mario Kart 8 with all all four of
us have bread on her face oh my gosh
because we spun the wheel someone
donated and we all landed on bread face
and then they were like how much for
everyone to do bread face so we all had
bread behind their glasses and we had to
play Mario Kart oh my gosh I applaud you
guys for taking that night shift because
I was trying to stay up and watch and I
definitely knocked out oh boy oh I
should have been paying attention oh my
god we're skipping directions here it's
like I think if you go to the last one
and then press like with the bumper you
can go back ok we're gonna use this
button match so we figured it out right
who looks like they're good at judo I
know let's see Eggman he's finally
started the arms I'm gonna be Sonic
because I love that boy
[Music]
you know peach looks like she's ready to
fight back and forth an a after grab
brick balance back and forth one grab to
maintain balance back and forth thank
you a lot of movement on the stick
Indians grabbing oh there's advanced
controls X advanced controls
step we are like wow we have special
counter-attacks
countdown with X gotta let your you know
you know what we just gotta do it right
I love that still in a dress hate judo
she's like Donkey Kong oh oh gotta go
fast gotta go fast
oh man I don't even ask I've no idea
what I was doing
gotta go fast this is on switch for
those hanging sonic chucked me out one
more time yeah here we go alright
Kyle said should I buy it
Oh we'll find out well yeah let's go
we've only done like two mini games so
far up for the grab engage let's go
let's go feet I'm like okay okay that's
something happened there
oh my god do some moves
shame you're still in the arena bozos
sorry still in the ring a we're in 1964
we time-traveling reverse good job well
played it's one one will play yeah we'll
do one okay so I think I get it now
right like we're moving back for it and
we try to grab each other and then
whoever initiator of the grab has to
like hold one direction and mash and the
other person has to like counter that
keep their little column straight got it
all right
yeah the first round he went so fast I
was like I have no idea which is okay
another inventor you want to play it
again we can is is two out of three
we're one right it's only four yeah one
one all right here we go
here we go gotta go fast
oh no oh you did it good job you figured
that out
nice all right how's the chat doing hey
guys thanks for joining us hello
gamespot thank you hey chat ladies just
joined in can you confirm if there's
online versus and do all the events have
joy Klein HT Rumble controls there's
online versus yes there is there's
online it's also local play and as far
as it looks all of them do have an
option for you to use the motion
controls we just haven't tried it out
yet
nice that's ok we got a long stream
ahead of us your choice what's only 1964
of us let's see it was a long jump you
know honestly I just remember doing this
one in track and field alright let's try
it out okay and let me know when you
want to switch to like joy Connor or
whatever I think we should save the joy
Connellan from when we do the not the
retro version got it it'll probably be
more of yeah early buttons only feels
right for me yeah I feel like this is
what we should be doing I'll be Mario
I'll beat the Braille audio it'sa me dr.
Eggman dr. Robotnik it should say
Robotnik he was Robotnik what is I
forgot to look up the controls is it
justice and then I think ffy to jump
she's like I don't know it all came back
to you track of the field just like
muscle memory and
like oh snap here we go oh no you did it
you did I went way too high I went up
and then I went down
second attempt here we go go Mario go
Mario Mario go where I go oh that was
close well very nice it was good job
Luigi I like Luigi I'm always cheering
for Luigi nyeeehhh yeah yeah that first
jump was ha beautiful
oh my head you're already lighting just
too modern instead of retro yes we are
but we have a long stream ahead so we
might as well play all of the minigames
enjoy yeah plus there's less retro games
in there are yes so this is a good way
to start off and also you know just
feeling nostalgic whoa whoa what is she
she's just drifting with her feet all
right Jess it's like hiding all the tech
let's do it
tilt up and down to move your speed
increases each time you press a alright
but doing so will deplete your stamina
watch out we're running into other
runners on the chorus edges will deplete
your stamina gauge repeat contact and
cause you to fall resulting in a big
loss of salmon speed water stations oh
gotta stay hydrated everybody press P at
a water station to grab a drink okay
runners will clump together in groups
and the race progresses running behind a
group use it as a windbreak all right
keep an eye under stamina gauge running
out of Salmonella cause you just slow
down oh boy let's give this right shots
guy go fast I'll be the rival oh boy
so basically you don't imagine that it
hit a okay his name is Robotnik sorry
here we go yeah my way my stamina my
stamina
oh I'm hitting everything why are you
running out of stamina so fast sonic I
think the more you manage to lower your
bar it goes oh there's walls Sonic you
gotta go fast I think I miss I say my
water I am NOT doing oh boy oh boy oh I
should have picked up some I don't when
are you ready games I'm like pressing it
every now and then and then just moving
up and down yeah okay he's like I'm
tired though it yeah Eggman's like I was
understand for this sorry
Eggman this is a mega I said sonic would
run away faster than I know right this
is my cannon this is a lie oh whoa where
are these hazards on the marathon course
what is that about they should have
fixed that before we got here puddles
everywhere I don't appreciate that at
all all right what I just learned that
by mistake completely all the water
refill my eyes come on
I tripped
this is a lie none of this is true get
out of my way
Becky go go sonic go there we go come on
come on oh no I need oh they're not
gonna be over out there they do that
Oh am I like Oh bananas bananas no these
this track and then I heard this track
is a hazard I could have used that I
just avoided it my bad okay
hydrate -
oh my god good job oh good job you're
way ahead of me you're way ahead of me
come on Sonic come on Sonic don't run
out of stamina it's important to stay
hydrated
oh no yes use it use it go goes on it go
goes on it go
you gotta think come on what was that oh
my god toad what are you doing here
there's like all sorts of toys all over
here no come on hi breakfast or
something okay so they meet the psych
you out right because they're like okay
100 meter run mash it as much as you can
and then the mat the marathon is like
all right like right off with it way too
fast so I'm learning what I did wrong
and I was doing just like up and down
because I thought I was supposed to be
up and down but it's like you can just
go straight oh yeah yeah on to the next
oh here we go
it does make sense the only ones you'd
like conservative and then the water
like the big cups give you like huge
the stamina back alright let's go back
let's look look at some modern stuff
okay so just go to that left took it
yeah there we go all right here we go
traveling to the future now what would
you like
I'm going for anything
they're pretty cool yeah I mean we're in
a racing mode let's try it yes bring it
to the future got some luck my homie
Yoshi here we go
Yoshii nice okay Waluigi if all we do is
choice I'm going with it here we go
let's see if the controls are different
than the nostalgia mode or the retro
mode that's a good point charge before
you start hold on okay okay
start a speed up man super - car okay
cool anytime we get the mash is a good
sign yeah advanced controls thrust chest
forward our that's a move got it mm-hmm
all right they're calling out different
things they want to see a 100-meter dash
bad yes we will do those we will 100% do
those there we go oh I messed up my damn
I did too early I also did too early
Danny oh Sh oh good
Yoshi's so good nice and we both you
guys be by second yeah we both worst
we're so good that we don't need it we
don't need the extra start it's fine
all right here we go
[Applause]
Sour Patch
okay do you want to play again or do you
wanna do a different event totally up to
you okay let's do another event we both
did really well there it's fine yeah
hurdles relay wait so what I thought
someone hype for badminton weird yep bad
mood okay
sure what's right stop it by the way
badminton in real life I feel like is so
hard I know I love it cuz it's so much
easier than tennis maybe my hand-eye
coordination is just bad this is really
do you want to be on the same team or
you want to be a different team will you
try Bowl
alright let's try it okay should we try
the solar remote here yeah I just want
to see if this controller since it's not
a joy Khan if I can still use it as okay
so I might be able to okay there we go
I'm gonna try not to throw those OC yeah
I can use this I'll go joy yeah I got
you yeah that's why I love this light
yeah so versatile so Ellen are
swing hood this is gonna be hard I know
I'm in this in this small room when you
start it it's like Oh make sure you have
plenty of space up to serve this is
gonna be I might move my confidence fire
hazard you can move with while your
opponent is okay
so swing it and move okay so yeah use
the anti lock to move around left cool
got it I'm super good too full hold are
or else different super shot
ooh no but you know what you know just
don't let go we got this don't know
being shadow it is fast it moving both
fast it moving here we go
all the Comptroller's your thumb press
is very cool okay got it
yep be careful y'all yeah well we'll do
our best
I don't know Q terrified alright let's
do this oh boy oh good
and I get that oh I don't know you got
it you got it yeah oh nice that was
quick match boy
oh oh that counter that went far that
dick over that went far nice alright so
how did you deal about those controls I
I actually didn't think it was that bad
it was alright I realized I couldn't I
was trying to like go over hand at the
beginning and it wasn't working so it
was all like underhand once I started
doing that it was alright underhand was
okay but like the response time was like
there's a slight delay yeah and it was
like I wasn't exactly that close but
when I did swing I was just in the
general area and it hit it for me
anyways why can't that happen in real
life
all right I wish you doubles now yeah
let's do it again
so she select event again yeah again
yeah there you go
badminton again doubles so what about
yeah got it got it
I think we got it figuring it out yeah
[Music]
two-on-one yeah I can have a teammate if
they owe it actually British
actually has a buff that's all tails has
precision zoom and go to Wales Louise
all right ready
[Music]
okay alright only going down yep oh I
miss I miss bad he psych me out
come on Sonic like it's delayed their
body
ding oh my god oh my god get these
prongs aboard gotta go fast that was
very fast all right
smashes jump smashes that's cool Amy so
cute all right
you should try full control or two with
the bat should we I feel like that'd be
hard this feels right this actually
feels like I was playing a little bit
and judging by how I like was not
running very far that's also a testament
to how I would play - yeah let's try
something we have so many try alright
what would you like to do next
let it all out in the chat what do you
want to see what do you guys want to see
let's play otherwise we'll we'll pick
some stuff I think we can go back to a
roller for the next one all right what
do you guys want to see pick something
I'm down for like some swimming or some
carrot a right well while we're waiting
okay I think I lost control yeah you
control over it okay I got it
we might need to reset our Yahweh the
recent rollers alright which one do you
want cool both did you said swimming
pleeeease cool
all right buttons oops wait we're just
resetting the controllers oh wait go
back
okay go back yeah we picked full joy
Khan and controlling mode oh right
oh no is it stuck I might be here yeah
first Ellen are
yeah here we go
I took it off let me take the other one
and then go back and fix swimming and
yeah there we go oh no did this turn off
okay whew yeah we're gonna swim in now
do it again here we go all right as the
event begins hold our charge power tilt
down it go okay cool and then I move the
six coordinates two characters jokes
tell swim faster you move quickly swim
Oh interesting keep a good pace little
super gauge but swimming too fast will
drain it all right whoa all right
well our sharks cage tilts down as a
fetcher kicks Walter okay interesting
all right let's do it oh boy waluigi he
is ready he's ready he's good at turning
oh we got some votes for a bunch of
stuff swimming fencing archery surfing
yep we'll get to all these yeah yeah
yeah okay one more time tried before
start with the are start down okay these
are alive this is a lot yeah all good
let's see if I can absorb this yeah
front crawl butterfly breaststroke you
know what always guys write it I guess
yeah interesting yeah let's do it
it's also a test of how fast you can
like absorb some information and make it
work there's a lot of minigames here
oops yep
oh wait I forgot what it was oh okay
oops Levi mom
lord I don't know what I'm doing whole
darn all right you guys okay nope this
is trickier than I thought okay
oh okay okay all right I got it way too
late I gotta turn I was like okay I
think we need to run that back okay cuz
I also missed what my stroke was I was
looking at the top screen I wasn't
thinking anything specific by the in
school that each character has something
individual be like there's all everyone
strokes are different all right let me
not flub this starts
now it's making sense now
that was weird cool
come on come on yeah exactly exactly
answer it's like once you actually
understand you're like wait I got to do
it again yeah need to do some of these
toys Eggman shorts Yoshi he's a free
spirit doesn't need any shirt
seeing Eggman shameless is nightmare
feels as charged
I forgot what everyone voted for we had
a lot I see a lot of skateboarding
fencing hates us swimming fencing okay
fencing was that equestrian which I
don't know what that is actually the
horse oh all right so we want to do
fancy skateboard okay
fencing it is team will do skateboard
after yeah try it as a team yeah what
this pay for him with your car this
looks violent right eat it you'll and I
hit sorry I'm here when you first to
reach ten points okay so it's up to hold
your sword high press a for a high lunge
tilt down hold sir Tyrone retreat what
to do a quick step this is some fighting
game separatist betta Perry high cool
down press P to parallel hi Perry low
Perry super gay hold our press a oh snap
okay alright we're gonna try it let's do
it let's let's fight each other first
okay take on another team oh we can
choose another teammate epping put it
step okay
I got a pic Waluigi I'm gonna pick my
best boys this is gonna be interesting
okay and China I think I remember the
game let's leave those controllers
running move flick to step on a weapon
high stance
okay hold weapon low stance high lunge
a low lunge a cool very very okay got it
got it
no they noted on guard Oh
ob is the pairing
they're making the cutest sizes oh boy
oh dang oh job Yoshi nice now the
secondary is Daisy's outfit Oh Harry
Oh
whoa yeah yeah
gotta go fast yeah oh no no no no no no
my journal in Iran oh that was delicious
I liked it that was vicious right well
that was wild yeah that was wild
I liked it good job that was fun I like
that one it was very fighting game yes
it was nothing it's like um that I feel
like that was almost on like divekick
levels of fighting game where it's like
it's simple but you do like have to have
that same type of exactly you're gonna
still be aware of the movements that are
happening so I feel like that's why
that's the only one we've been good at
immediately like ah let's fight again
okay all right so let's play it again
now we know what we're doing yeah okay
okay I mean I kind of know
ooh a nice sorry wha oh I guess I can't
parry that huh no yeah I can't hear it
oh I'm bad at that timing oh yeah I'm
back baby
sounds good
hey cool is Rotem
welcome wait to the part of it yeah 202
of the best host really because rocky
you're so sweet please oh yeah we're
having a good time we're just playing
some Mario & Sonic at the Olympic Games
Tokyo 2020 hmm anything in the beginning
that kind of gave you like a yeah we
were just wondering that yeah I think it
you have to have the exact timings as it
starts which did not happen I think they
do have some sort of blocking if you
just hold back cuz a few times it
actually block the attack just by
holding back and I think that was fun
yeah I like that one a lot actually I
was that was a lot of fun
[Applause]
that's good you want a tiebreaker you
want to go to another event we could do
another one cuz we did one single one oh
it was both teams actually yeah that's
you
doesn't matter oh we do versus them this
time or we pick something else that's it
what are they had a high request for
skateboarding oh boy and equestrian
uh-huh
alright so in order of the requests we
had in boxing and harassing archery ok
archery was next after that ok archery
was the next vote from the chat
individual duel controllers button so
since you have a pro controller yeah
buttons only ok hold l2 raise your bow
then hold our to draw the bowstring ok
ok use this okay two consecutive scores
at least nine points will make your next
shot a super shot Wow all right let's
see who's got good aim controls it's
precision while we do spit it away I
need to stop yeah boy I got any to stop
using Waluigi all around yeah Amy let's
go I'm an all-around lady
let's go sounded straightforward enough
yeah
well it's really fun
oh we're at the same time ok
and practice drawing the okay yeah that
was an accident but it actually was not
about uh alright
practice drawing and I see okay huh
stone the red grant well I got some
practice wounds and laughs yeah
[Applause]
Oh Oh we get a third one right let's see
so that was it
so give you how is it I thought it was
like if you scored nine points or more
in the first two you get a third one
that does more but I didn't let us do
that there yeah I guess we didn't score
high and around to you Oh round two here
we go
next shot is a super shot orange Elbe
Woods was just too intense for me I
almost messed that up really far now
yeah super okay okay okay we got a third
round here
oh that was so bad I wonder if this
would be more fun with just single joy
poems Oh
[Applause]
lift it all right
very far whoa hmm not so good for Amy
yeah so you get a aim super high oh yeah
so so far all right okay
[Applause]
she's doing great he said yeah all right
what is the next vote was a seaport I
feel like someone's very excited for
skateboarding in the child yes all right
skateboarding let's give it a shot
this is Newton he dons a spin everything
will be okay jumps are high turns are
tight fast at moving all around all
right
[Music]
shadows paper
he seems like a skateboarding kind of
boy Brandon's a bo she's definitely from
my with those big I'm about it I love it
oh snap I'm shadow like super cool
windows up oh we didn't like controls
yeah we kind of just went in well oh
yeah
I'm just hitting a when they telling me
to basically and just trying to get a
good oh I did keep nice
a little a my bad gonna be some sort of
flip in my ear here yeah did you play
Tony Hawk pro skater I did except me my
brother used to cheat we used to do the
infinite grind this would feel a lot
better if skal was playing oh yeah but
it's still pretty fun look at said Manny
the cameras over there what a guy
you girls get your ollie on yeah Thank
You Rudy fine no is really fun we should
look at the controls yeah we jumped in
there we just jumped right in and I just
like was trying to channel my pony head
first game I did some spins but not
enough spins clearly that was fun Shadow
feels like a real skateboarder today
right boys are going to the skate park
it's definitely shadow he looks like the
type to be like repping independent the
whole time they had the same color
scheme yes but I said Scott this would
feel a lot better if Scott was playing
let's try this again and actually look
at the convenience good idea okay who
else looks like a skateboard boy
I see tails looks like he can shred all
right where is the control for really
okay thank you right move on grind and
slides maintain balance super trick hold
RNA that's what I wasn't doing
all right what's our advance control
switch stance would be manual flip spin
the board it was landing boost okay all
right let's do it
let's give it a shot yes Goldfinger come
on dude
make me proud
yeah spin boy oh dang oh dang oh yeah
[Applause]
he's got style
8
Mushu late our tails tails my boy
Oh nap
[Applause]
all I almost combo that manuals into the
grain Shadow was a much better
skateboarder that song as so legendary
just because I came that's very true
[Applause]
alright there you go yep there's
skateboarding or didn't there
skateboarding for you all right what is
next well we're we had some votes for
karate and for some boxing I think one
person I'll be up a foot long equestrian
surfing alright
surfing equestrian karate okay yeah
what's the difference between karate and
dream karate I know right alright so
question first
it's time to ride some horses and oh
snap take our horses to the old sound
road as the event begins hold our to
charge power press a at go to start
writing tilts in the direction you want
to turn already as you enter the jump
zone press a to make your horse jump
press a to use her horses stamina and go
faster already use a super dash dash is
very fast can only be used once okay oh
good to keep in mind yo she gallops fast
fast
Sonic's little outfit like in a question
I like oh yo she has no costumes he's
just Yoshi he is in his only attire is
the only attire he everything you try to
start start move jump speed up super -
okay oh right we're gonna give it a shot
give it our best
aha
flubbed it yep
get started too early oh yeah can you
jump can you jump where you going
they go the wrong way sure did
I thought that was the track oh the
yellow marks the track I'm trying to go
on different tracks and it's not clearly
not working job
okay all right okay
jump again did it yeah run right up into
that thing why don't you okay I messed
up my poor horse I'm so sorry my voice
is tired already
yeah she's like you don't knock me into
every single barrier you fit Oh not
enough speed oh I'm so sorry Horace look
my horse is so mad at my horse case yeah
oh yeah my horse was not about that
yeah those tough do you want to try it
again oh yeah I told you forgot we had a
super - yeah me too
because I was just trying not to run
into things okay let's let's travel it's
got the charge just touch this
yes that was like
yeah dude let's go go horse go go horse
go okay
wasn't anything I'm just thinking about
how I didn't tweet I was gonna be honest
because I knew I could be doing terribly
it wave not touch this game also now and
I am doing horrendous
like I cleared it but the game was to
like that was still a little late I'm
drying my Wang
spoken like a true asian mom game oh my
bad I'm just gonna run into this just
gonna run into it's go yeah do it not
enough speed such disappointment it's my
- like right in the last 2 point I
forgot about my - again boy all right
Yoshi Yoshi with a comeback
Bowser beat me how are so big how did he
make the worst job you know his poor
horse how did he make the horse jump
[Laughter]
alright well there you go Andrew said
can you try motion controls again with
the question oh yeah let's try it once
it might be I would assume it's like
tilt controls how do we do that oh wait
did it even give you the option I don't
know oh yeah Oh duel it's only duel
sorry you only have one set of joique on
so we can't do it yeah I'm using a pro
Concetta alright cool cool cool what
next
so that was karate and seriously winning
right which one first let's do some
hottie yeah all right
karate it is each hit you land will
score your point okay
like the fencing press a to punch
punches are quick would have to limited
reach the second so successful punch
will earn you one point press X to kick
oh all right this is like Oh slower than
punches but have longer reach a
successful kick with our new one point
when a super gauge is full press R to do
a super strike a successful super strike
warranty five points okay and she's a
good fighter
i'ma try Belize actually yeah my try
Belize let's see what advanced controls
they have for us here yeah oh my bad
y'all good here we go hi guys sorry our
chat was stuck yeah Irish I was stuck I
was like oh no one's saying no no they
are okay the horse game is so intensive
oh yes yes I am here Eddie what is it
hey what's up yeah let's see these
controls alright move analyst block I
like how they did not teach this bad but
Ellis block alright fYI punches a kick
his ex okay takedown is why super
straight car alright power punch power
alright power punch punch beep okay
let's give it a shot
shall we indeed hi Phillip how are you
today we're good oh well oh wow Oh what
nice
Oh Eddie my name is chasity thank you
for joining us I'm usually on GameSpot
universe which is our entertainment
channel youtube.com slash insight
universe all right oh yeah yeah no one
more one more
Joanne you want a different character
that's my homie right there I can tell
you've been using that he's been doing
great and a lot of these events Oh No
oh yeah my oh oh I'm not sure what
happened I'm not sure thanks Philip
we're having fun time out okay I like
I'm so confused
all right all right no I've been here
for three years actually I've when
working at Gamestop for three years I've
been on a bunch of streams but I mostly
am a senior producer who kind of runs
things behind the scenes so I'm not on
screen as much as I like but I am here
I've been here for a while
yeah but I'm usually doing a TV and
movie content that's why you're probably
not used to me all right
that was regular karate yeah let's let's
punch it up Susie and her happy and see
what that's about
whoa this is definitely yes this is
lifting all right when wow what is happy
I know what what is this all right when
you knock your opponent's down the
panel's they land on become yours that's
funny oh this this is something else
ate a punch next to kick okay okay hold
a or hold X to turn your punch or kick
into a power strike I got longer the
charge longer the range will be it's why
to throw your opponent okay
whoa this looks in yeah this is a lot
this is all like a fool
tbh all right what up welcome back so
chill
hello how goes it yeah it's okay we're
playing tons of minigames what's up so
shield
alright I'm gonna do
[Music]
shadow
and Google's run is that it turns into
bloodsport basically yeah this escalated
quickly
yeah I have to channel my inner
jean-claude whoa
yeah well oh oh all right give me that
star yes come here no beer beach oh wow
Oh Jimmy with a three-piece oh oh oh I
need that emerald no you give it back I
had like this little slide here whoa oh
it's not even a ravening I have no white
but I'm pretty sure I've traced roots
but what part of the Olympics is this I
like it I wish this was part of the
Olympics may be in Tokyo 2020 we'll find
out yeah that was good that was good
[Laughter]
turns into bloodsport yeah it sure did
all right this is the cell tournament
from DBZ super saiyan blue super saiyan
god super Yoshi I'm about it I'm about
it all right
was that chaotic or try again that was
definitely chaotic we'll try something
else like what else were we asked for
surfing yes we were asked for sir oh so
maybe that's semi similar to the
skateboarding oh yeah mechanics but
we'll find out
solar remote what ha what it are we just
like doing this we're like syncing our
phone to the GPS again else try buttons
only on that cuz that feels wrong I
don't I feel like I could surfing by
moving like I want you to stand on the
joy Khan competitors are ranked based on
this whole amount of points they score
press a to begin paddling and catching a
wave ok waves can vary in height and
length be sure to catch a good one tilts
left or right to turn in that direction
press a to do an aerial trick type of
trick depends on what direction it's
tilted got just full press a while
holding our to do a super trick all
right we'll try our best sure thing
tube writing yo daisy'll is definitely
bodying me and dream karate I was like
trying to charge up my punch she's like
nah I'm out of here
all right
yeah
all right so we paddling we paddling
catch good with all right oh yeah oh
yeah noise
Oh
Valentin troll
keep your balance Amy keep your bow I
know y'all know do it my dress stay on
that board and we're just trying to ride
this wave I think I don't think I did a
single trick let's try to stay I just
was saying that I was trying not to
dress I'm pretty sure I succeeded in
that
that was tough that says I remember a
big wave
I only like to serve to the lilo and
stitch soundtrack thank you cool
I'm doing stuff yeah and we got to do a
trick oh this is more than I can surf in
real life I cannot see I've never been
into everything and I'm too terrified to
serve to be honest I almost drowned when
I was five so I'm really afraid of
putting my head underwater yeah that's a
lot yeah
tentative so I basically only swim on my
back
hey I know it's something I should get
over but fears or fears man Johnny Utah
would be proud Oh tangled Go Go all
right Oh Amy looks so cute
mm-hmm was surfed yes Prince Hawaiian
rollercoaster ride that's a good surfing
book oh yeah
instantly lo and said like in my mind
yes all right well there you go yeah we
done surfed we did it
what's next you guys canoe I heard
someone say canoe yeah canoe it is hold
on tight okay yeah yeah okay
so down I go to start okay tilt down the
paddle okay gotcha Matt you're paddling
speed with your partners to go faster if
chiming is off you'll slow down oh boy
so we have to be like in sync with each
other all righty
okay with the boy
[Music]
yes brothers away oh yeah dad more and
my enemy the evil version of me oh why
thank you Terry says I'd appreciate
y'all playing this we're having a good
time thanks for watching you guys been
hanging out all right so what was the
charge was it R or was it a my charger
man we could never be what it used to be
it was our I messed up I did here i 100%
messed up
oh yeah
oh yeah what's a rhythm game alright
let's go
ah I thought they'd sign at the
beginning yes still we are not in sync
with each other I shouldn't have picked
enemies try that one again yeah try name
one one more time we're not very
synchronized me and Louise were the
dream events like they're chaos we did
drink bourbon and it was a free-for-all
[Applause]
right yeah I want to select character
okay they were not in sync with each
other at all
I need my girl enemy to figure this out
for me and Bowser jr. all right let's do
it
okay let's try yeah so it was our yes
all right penalize me it was like
absolutely not Jesse what do you think
you're doing
I'm getting it
I'm so confused oh now see it's like oh
I was the dings were helping me I was
using the dings so like the last hundred
meters you can just see Wow all right
didn't realize that it's okay still did
good but yeah the dings in the beginning
early there we go so they also have
dream erasing and dream shooting oh boy
so let's just show them these are nuts
oh boy
this is like what is this an over 100
well this is Tokyo 2020 Olympic Games
but it seriously just reminded me of
over there like what is happening okay
shoot the targets Wow okay use press B
to jump okay aim by tilting tilting the
controller and press wow I'm gonna floor
it look kite targets okay this looks
nutty this crater I'm gonna need some
help aiming so while we use your back in
that is definitely your back and hold
the controller so your thumb press is
a-okay
short-term memory is bad okay
aim tilt up okay rotate right she exits
multi-shot that sounds like an important
thing that they didn't die multi shot
okay let's give it a shot let's see what
happens these motion controls are nutty
I don't like them no they're so
sensitive - yeah barely touch it
they're so sensitive all right oh wow
Waluigi is making the wrong choices oh
boy okay who where are these hurts
wow I'm bad okay
Wow Wow Waluigi that was weird oh my hi
it's okay
far away from the line I'm here where
are these kites inside says don't go up
there
but testaments alright alright I don't
even know where the kites are there in
the middle and like we have to like go
through this how sizing AHA there we go
no I was waiting for a way that we're
gonna happen oh man
okay okay Oh No
yes so the motion controls are extremely
sensitive see the stomach luckily it was
like a little bit of a Halloween if you
get it generally over the target ginger
oh okay oh whoa whoa okay boss I'm down
I'm too far away for that I know Dean
Oh minimal touch-up I gotta get in there
dude
where are you okay okay all right here
you are
oh man being in the trench is not a good
idea let you guys know that right now
[Music]
finally all again next time I'm just
gonna stay in the middle fire right all
right good job Yoshi proud of you man
these dream games aren't messing around
yeah yes the motion controls are always
way too sensitive for me us too that was
it's not working for me it's getting
interesting yeah I really wanted to
fight the kite bosses about never in did
you want to try that again right now we
could try it one more time just because
I want to fight the kind yeah I know I
need to be in the middle now I felt like
I missed out
[Applause]
Wow Waluigi gosh come on right there
yeah oh these open doors
[Music]
okay I was like I'm gonna stay in here
here we go
[Music]
Selma's sounds like we love him yeah all
right we got it at a time very nice
better there's the final kite boss
I want him I'm like wasting time out
here staying in the middle but I don't
want to miss the guy boss
yeah thinking I stayed close Waluigi is
having the time of his life he's just
like wah wah wah no get out there kid
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
alright alright take that kite boss good
job Yosh I'm proud of you she that was a
better performance
yeah the multi-shot liked it I guess
those little gold square things when I
win the kite boss came out I'd hit it
once and it gave me a ton of points so
that's definitely by the way all right
yeah once you get used to how sensitive
the motion controls are then it's a
little bit better alright let's try now
discus throw yeah that's like a classic
like Olympic game in my opinion for sure
okay tilt up to take your stance and get
ready
rotate class was to charge your power
gauge try to angle a controller 3000 you
want me to do math math and press some
text to throw okay too much power result
in the foul well let's try our best Lord
laureen's your best bring me back oh boy
all right controls again get ready sweep
back rotate clockwise throw with X okay
and stay at 35 degrees no pressure do
you have to raise the controller up to
like I think ever so slightly
I know boy this is gonna be fantastic
I've already forgotten the control cuz
I'm worried about 35 degrees so filled
up throws it down so what's up
back lift it okay sweep back nope nope
so that red bar on the side you can't go
too far up and that comes in the
rotation part okay that's better I did
one-oh is that the actual first one I
thought we were stay not too far off
from each other could you have you done
okay that was it ding we got one Joe all
right
oh there we go good attempt - ok
I like this over do it girl
hey freeze for Amy yeah all right all
right yeah wait Louie beat us what the
heck don't try again yeah let's try that
one again let's try it one more time
tots up what are your thoughts on the
game so far I think it's got a lot of
fun minigames some of them are more easy
to pick up than others the dream ones
were chaotic but I'm not mad at it I
think it's it's fun it's a fun game to
play with your friends I with that oh I
did too strut again sorry no I can't
talk in Disqus at the same time I'm not
there yet
you like that 36 degrees almost almost
16 degrees I clearly there's no idea
I was like 30 more days I made it it's
fine
whoa I was not no guilt for discus you
guys nope that wasn't happening oh look
how sad they are look what I said it's
all fun and games and then the
developers put math and said Theodore
come on listen I was way better at
English I was not good at math yeah
we're definitely having fun with this
though we're also both lovers of
mini-games like at home yeah I love
pokemon stadium I love Mario Party he
said yeah all right let's see something
else not that that was hard swimming was
hard I did not like it Oh gymnastic I
don't know what's hard it does like
alright did that table senses is
whatever it's your base it's basically
badminton tennis yeah really yeah let's
do one of the races okay let's do
hurdles let's see how many hurdles we
can hit with our own faces it'll be all
of them as event begins hold our charge
power press a it go to start running
press a repeatedly to run faster press
the button the faster you run after the
jump zone press B to jump okay what
should it be so we have to press do us
with mash a the whole time more or less
cuz I'm putting the controller down on
the table
Oh shadow you sound weird
I did not like that
alright three Undertaker that was for
you I picked shadow for you also I just
wanted to pick shadow but his voice is
threw me off re are oh whiff tit sorry
I'm LT early oh I am screwing up that
was fast
alright let's try that again thank you
wow the a button is getting a workout
that is so true and our thumbs let's try
that again
yeah agreed Tokyo 96 for games yeah we
did that at the beginning of the the
stream but we can do some more for those
that missed it if you want to see the
old-school stuff let's switch back to it
in a second then said that's not the
shadow I remember no all right that's we
got this then were you talking about his
voice cuz that was something
[Applause]
oh so well suited good either good nice
good stuff look at him go yay shadows
like unamused but still waving anyway
like whatever okay Eddie wants to see
the 1964 games again so we'll go back to
that if you missed it from the beginning
of the stream we played a bunch of the
old ones so let's look at these old
songs right did we not do yet
volleyball we didn't do shooting we
didn't do kayak bolts Oh Dean oh yeah
all right yeah Oh cute dude all right I
always think of Coneheads yes yeah or
she doesn't dive there's like nothing to
that Zoey this looks okay like the dive
when standing up Wow okay with each
having their own set of commands are you
kidding me yeah it's like with executed
combo okay wow these are long dude like
more than what this is I'm gonna whip
this that go enter the first command to
begin your dive if you enter the
sequence quick enough extra commands
will appear giving you a chance to earn
a higher oh okay I'm gonna try my best
oh all right Oh genie mama all right
sanic okay the other green bud
[Music]
it me okay okay okay you just start with
the things the buttons and not the dough
I was doing I was like I'm trying
up-down huh it's because there's no
letters damn it all right yeah there
were no letters look what I'm doing up
down up with that don't give me a score
that was careless no don't give me a
score that was awful okay all right now
you know that their buttons there
they're not directions they're not right
okay
oh nice oh good job Luigi Wow okay now I
know that their buttons let's try this
oh do you have to hit it I don't know
either I did it yeah once before I have
no idea what they want to do
all around see up up up left down down
yes timing okay got it
cute very nice good music so game that's
great so it's all about timing yeah I
kind of just rushed it down so maybe if
you leave too much time it's really okay
try simple yeah and then you could do
the extra ones as you're falling if you
want more points got it
cute that's better sorry Sonic I did him
dirty it's fine we can run it back I did
him so dirty he's so mad at me Oh oh man
thank this mess emotion messed up my
follow up such a long fall Wow okay cool
well did you see the question mark one
at the bottom left whoops missed that
one I saw that there was one that was a
bunch of question marks oh I wonder if
that's just like a wildcard one give it
your best
I kinda wanna know see what oh oh my god
what okay oh that was never gonna happen
for me I didn't make the full room
[Music]
cute all right we got five minutes left
in the stream we'll do a couple more
minigames yeah what was your favorite
minigame so far hmm I don't know they
were all pretty good so far
I got like fencing that's fine oh we
have another dream one we didn't oh yeah
you should do one more old one or yeah
let's do let's do the 400 meter hurdles
okay see how they do it though let's
give a shot hold a two charged power
released a to start just a Dorothy Lee
go faster and through the gemstone press
B okay that's pretty self-explanatory he
can sanic
we actually did do the marathon line
earlier in the stream Jericho and that
one's actually pretty cool cuz I gotta
like hydrate and not hit all this oh
that was hard I screwed that up
royally I messed up that start god whoa
is it be to jump yeah not for me come on
[Music]
[Laughter]
and then peach and tail zero it up
alright we'll go back to regular
graphics oh yeah go back to 2020 Tokyo
2020
alright alright what is this dream
racing whoa like escape where you're
easy danton's this crazy all right all
right reg power press 8 go to start left
or right hey to jump letting a long rail
tilts to keep your balance carne de cebú
tre
so it takes elements of some things that
we've done previously here we go
you're right Brandon slang should be
faster all righty
was a whole day hard and then press a I
go oh where am I going
I'm on the rails I'm on the rails yeah
that we got something Mario Kart
actually yeah oh wow yeah that was Mario
Kart oh and we get like this loop it's
so cute oh my girl oh my god
oh that was Carl's
Luigi oh my god tails and Luigi just
teens up on me right there that's not
nice no who has done this me seems like
Mario Kart it is which is don't hit that
man I got it it's not oh man almost got
bumped into that oh boy
no I wouldn't go in that thing oh I
missed it yeah it hurts I also have no
rings I ever just the failure never say
that about my friend I
oh okay
yes how did I get to 6,000 seconds this
is oh boy
I blame these items yeah I done got
electrocuted like 10 times already
oh I'm doing so bad the games like here
at stake a star oh man I wish I got on
top of that rail up there oh that was
rough that was rough that was rough
yes we are reading this but between
games I know
direct my full attention to the screen
all right 12:30 it is indeed that that
was our last one you guys that was Mario
and Sonic at the Olympic Games Tokyo
2020 thanks for joining us yes and if
you like what you saw the game is
available now it just came out to date
you have a Nintendo switch yeah so go
ahead and snag that if you liked it I
definitely did economies play some more
minigames through the winter but I would
like to play my Spotify with the Tony
Hawk pro skater so definitely alright
you guys well thank you for tuning in
and don't forget every weekday at 11
a.m. Pacific time at GameSpot laughs pop
in so I hope to see you guys tune back
in with us next time and I hope you have
a good day see you later
[Music]
you